le chef de l'État évoque dans des
confidences rapporté par les journaux
l'hypothèse de sa défaite comment est-ce
que vous l'interprétez écoutez je crois
que c'est assez normal de considérer que
on n'est pas sûr de gagner et peut-être
même qu'on risque de perdre par
conséquence je trouve ça assez banal la
la
dégradation de la situation du président
de la République depuis plusieurs mois
et même on peut dire depuis le début
depuis son élection c'est confirmé et il
atteint maintenant des niveaux à partir
duquel il pourrait presque trouver du
pétrole oui et vous pensez qu'il a déjà
perdu on n jamais déjà perdu mais enfin
tout de même il est considérablement
affaibli dans l'opinion et il est je
crois il a perdu le il n'a plus la
chance il a été très servi par la chance
dans sa carrière politique et quand on a
la chance et bien tout ce qu'on fait
même d'idiot ça réussit quand on a plus
la chance tout ce qu'on fait même
d'intelligent ou d'actif ça vous fait
perdre en tous les cas lui déclare en
cas échec j'arrête la politique est-ce
que vous le croyez oui je le crois il
m'a dit un jour vous savez ce que je
fais je le fais avec passion mais je me
sent très capable de faire autre chose
par que j'avais pensé à partir de là
qu'il n'était pas foncièrement attaché à
sa mission qui n'était pas charnellement
attaché au mandat qu'il sollicitait mais
vous avez d'ailleurs toujours eu des
doutes sur le fait qu'il allait se
représenter Jean-Marie Le Pen oui oui
j'ai j'ai toujours pensé qu'il pouvait
ne pas se représenter et peut-être même
nous faire une petite entour Loupette
politique en en parlant le plus tard
possible et en nous mettant devant le
fait accompli d'un candidat qui serait
en quelque sorte assez lisse comme une
comme une anguille difficile à attraper
parce que personne n'aurait préparé ses
batteries contre le candidat nouveau de
l'UMP ah bon ça c'est une hypothèse qui
est renforcée selon vous selon ces
confidences du chef de l'État non enfin
c'est une hypothèse de travail dis ah
oui mais alors alors c'est en Guille ce
serait qui pour vous je sais pas ça peut
être le premier ministre